[Music]
so when they needed us we could fight
the battles that they never could so
tell me where the Avengers are now
because we're you know you mentioned it
where we last left off thinks it kind of
blown up a little bit when we last you
know saw these characters and Civil War
it's been probably in two or three years
that have passed and our characters have
been you know kind of part of some sort
of counter terrorism efforts but we're
you know flying under the radar and you
know it's a lot I think when you are you
know on these kinds of missions with no
governmental support you don't really
have the support of even you know even
just the general public and you know
you're sort of running the rogue you
know trying to do what you know is best
for the common man but you're not you
know you don't have you don't have
someone to kind of guide you or like I
said support you and so we're we kind of
are fractured ourselves you know and
then of course the last we saw Hulk he
was like floating into the stratosphere
now we are you know reintroduced to this
whole expanded universe there's been a
lot of change that's gone on since the
original Avengers assembled I feel like
it's bigger that they're bigger and
better and you know better than each one
before and this one is better in a good
way this one has 64 Marvel characters is
it really 64 that's why I didn't told
and Anthony and Joe they posted this
aerial shot of trailer village and it
was like nothing I've ever seen before
have you guys seen it I'm just reading a
circular yeah maybe like half of those
are our DJs yeah that's true actually
yeah we actually it's kind of like we're
making three movies all at once you know
it's very plot driven
and it's kind of this is a film I think
that really it you know all we have to
all of these pieces come together in a
very like in a kind of complex intricate
package and that's what this that's the
purpose I think of this film is to sort
of bring everything together in a
coherent way and so as that's happening
it feels sort of like there are kind of
three movies going on at once because we
meet different characters in different
circumstances and this one kind of
greater cause brings everyone together
and so it's we even haven't had the
opportunity to work with you know I mean
probably 75 percent of those 60 whatever
people just because you know their
characters are off in some other having
some realm yeah it really takes
crossover to a whole new level
mm-hmm I mean Avengers guardians of the
galaxy and I'm thinking about that and
I'm thinking Chris Pratt sarcasm sarcasm
Robert Downey jr. sarcasm senior I mean
is it like a sarcastic off I think they
do a good job of taking you know and
sprinkling those guys around you know I
don't think there's this time yes thank
God yeah well I just try to employ as
many women as possible in my like circle
just to try to kind of balance it out so
now I'm like yeah I can just I don't
have the full responsibility of the only
estrogen factor you know in this
production but yeah it's odd screaming
it started out with what we had Colby of
course is awesome and you know and Lizzy
who's been great and I actually I
haven't really had the opportunity to
work with I mean other than deny I mean
there's so it's the like I said the
universe is so big now that and you want
to bring them on my jeans all they say
you're still surrounded by a yeah
I mean pumped about brie Larson is
captain yeah oh yeah I got it she's
great I'm that's a very welcome addition
yes any anybody basically that is you
know of the female Jean yeah gender I
don't even care if you're an actor could
be a barista agent just for you come
when will we get a black widow movie
yeah no we made one oh god no I I don't
know I mean I you know I just want to
yeah I think that there's a it's such a
loaded question yes I would want to in
the right context and you know for the
film to fit where I'm in you know I am
in my life I'm you know play this
character for a long time it's been
probably like eight years or more and
more um you know it's so much has
happened in my life and happening in my
life as a performer happen in my life
personally and I think that you know it
would be theirs I love playing this
character and I think that there is
definitely an opportunity to explore the
widow as a you know as a woman who has
kind of come into her own and is making
independent and active choices for
herself
probably for once in her life you know
she hasn't always had that had that
possibility so if it fit though that
criteria they don't yes they do want to
do so I think they can make it up I
think what you say so much has changed
now you're not just a superhero in this
world but you're you're a mommy who's a
superhero yeah
yes that impacted you and how you
approach it
oh yeah it's I mean it's really been
great just to I you know I think that my
daughter now is she's gonna be three
years old and so she's really kind of is
starting to have an understanding of
what I do in the world that I
you know that I work in an associates of
species Suzy but she loves to come on
set she loves to she's really
enthusiastic she she she's totally you
know she's quiet when she has to be
she's really observant and more than
anything and she's not she's 2 years old
yeah yeah when she needs to move you're
doing a good job good job
I just don't feed her if you know but
she she you know what's really exciting
is being able to have her just be a part
of you know see that she you know her
mom loves what she does and you know
that I'm working with such a great group
of people and that my work environment
is so positive and I think that's that's
really fun is that when I say you know
you want to see mommy's work for the
gallery she loves it that she enjoys it
yeah sends a strong message oh my god
it's so I feel so lucky not everybody is
able to bring your kid to the work place
and and certainly on this job there's
actually a lot of a lot of a lot of us
have kids now and you and we all started
out we were young and unafraid and now
we're all I'm at the bar alone whenever
the pre-dinner drinks but after dinner
drink is all over it's great I brought
my dog so that's my child
it's it's been great I mean it's so nice
just to kind of watch the evolution just
I mean independent of the movies just
the friendships he gets before I'm
watching them grow and evolve and soon
we've known for a long time become
parents kind of just you know morph into
their adulthood is really a beautiful
thing
this has been what nearly a decade so
this process this franchise so you guys
really have become close I'm a family in
a way right yeah yeah I'm I'm excited
for even our the next infinity where
this thing really does go on forever
but you know we even get to it will even
be like a I think more of an opportunity
for ads all these pieces come together
you know you know we'll really have an
opportunity to work you know always kind
of a you know you're never going to get
what about the romances
I mean Black Widow and the Hulk there's
always been this unfulfilled Wow going
on there this tension but you know for
Captain America and what they call you
guys like yeah I mean I think you know
yeah it's hard to say I don't think that
romance has ever really been in the air
for these two it just doesn't seem sorry
to disappoint but I was like oh no I
agree that I think I think there's a
functionality there there's there's
there's a void that they each fill for
each other and I think they've each kind
of had to face a little bit of kind of
like a destruction of a belief system
along the way and I think they've each
leaned on one another for different
reasons
I think in a lot of ways cap certainly
looks up to Black Widow I think she's
always been a little wiser a little more
experienced a little more calloused and
the way the world really is and I think
in civil war you know Steve Rogers had
to learn the hard way that things that
you're banking on don't always sometimes
let you down and and I think in the past
couple years before we pick up in this
film they've really kind of become this
rock for one another but it
I don't know they'd ever bleed into a
Roman
and I think they also have a kind of you
know they have such a mutual respect for
one another or I think personally and
professionally that I I think that a
romance would be it would just be comp I
don't even think there's a room for a
romance in this like I don't think they
have the perspective you know to even
give room for something like that to
grow we've got a world to save
[Music]